The Golden Globes
were last night,
and the stars were out in force
for Hollywood's fifth or
sixth biggest platform
for actors
to make political statements
instead of just
accepting their awards.
Uh, to recap... to recap...
Casey Affleck appeared
to have been bitten by
-a radioactive rabbi, and...
-(laughter, applause)
And everyone loved La La Land,
the feel-good musical
that was set in L.A.
that proves that anyone can make
it as long as you got
a song in your heart,
a dance in your step,
and you're two of the most
attractive people on the planet.
(laughter)
Now, in case you didn't know,
Hidden Figures and Fences
are two
entirely different movies
featuring African-American leads
that both received
multiple nominations.
But shh! Don't tell that
to red carpet reporter
Jenna Bush Hager. Shh!
So, you're nominated
for Hidden Fences.
How cool is it?
You said
that this party's known
for a little drinking.
Are you thinking
you're going to partake?
-(laughter, applause & cheering)
-I mean...
-I mean, Pharrell's not even...
-BETSY BRANDT: Oh, my God!
-(bleep)
-He's not even angry.
-You just hear him deflate.
You know this... -(laughter)
The only thing this was missing
was the Curb Your Enthusiasm
music sting. Watch.
So you're nominated
for Hidden Fences.
(theme music for
Curb Your Enthusiasm plays)
(laughter, applause)
Ah! Curb.
Your music makes
everything better,
-including porn.
-Oh, my God.
-BRANDT: Oh, my God!
-Now, I know this looks bad,
but let's give her
the benefit of the doubt.
You know, Hidden Fences is...
Maybe it's a real movie
somewhere.
Maybe that is a real movie
Comedians, give us the tag line
for Hidden Fences....
Dan.
Um, will Stevie Wonder be able
to get his lawnmower business
off the ground and avoid all
the obstacles in suburbia?
Tune into Lifetime
original movie Hidden Fences.
(laughter, applause)
I mean, I think you just
sold the show, Dan.
You just sold the show.
Points to that.
-Betsy.
-BRANDT: Okay.
I have not seen Hidden Fences,
but I know all you have to say
is that it's very important.
It's very important. Yeah.